the jurogan experience i i tell you this
flying into texas right um
on an aircraft i was on um one of the
flight uh attendants
came up and kind of tapped me on the
shoulder as we were getting ready to
land and said well be careful because
you know
you know texas has gotten rid of the
mask mandate so and and and the point
was from the flight attendant was
you know this should just say it to you
yeah it's going to be like alexis yeah
it's a wild west
well you know just like mr baker and you
be careful out there because you know
cause i like you yeah
and uh and so but but my wife was
sitting right next to me there was
nothing untoward it wasn't like
no we were not engaged in any
shenanigans but but the point was
was that they looked at and they go oh
you know governor abbott said this and
it's political right
but my point of my story is i walked off
the plane
everybody was wearing a mask yeah this
is the thing the government
governor rather abbott said he said i
encourage you to wear a mask you should
still wear a mask but i don't want the
state
to tell you what to do right right
that's what i support
and if you don't want the state to tell
you what to do you shouldn't want the
federal government exactly telling you
what to do exactly
exactly but everybody i've seen in
austin where you're in a mask yeah
yeah yeah yeah well until you go to a
restaurant and you sit down then there's
no mask and i don't understand that
wow the whole thing is nonsense you have
to wear a mask when you go to pee
and then you don't wear a mask when you
come back and get back at your table
like okay
i mean because you know to be fair
they've got you know mostly six foot
distance
you know they haven't the places that
i've been here in texas
uh they they keep the social distance
but i guess my point was like you get
this
and we talked about this earlier off uh
before the show
but was the idea that some people just
like to suffer and they suffer well
right they enjoy the fact that
this is this is hard and bad and that's
really sad
but it's true there's people that they
enjoy being depressed it's it's a hard
thing to
to even say because you don't want it to
be real you know
you don't want there to really be people
out there that like
when there's some people that when we
got shut into our homes
and everyone was sad and everyone was
scared
they enjoyed it because that's how they
live all the time yeah yeah
yeah or there's just it's their time to
shine some people
have have really shown during the
pandemic
yeah and it's like i saw this post from
this this
individual who was a professional uh
clearly from their job
and they they posted ah i'm dealing with
such anxiety now because of the
possible return to normal and the idea
that i'm gonna have to travel and i
won't be able to have dinner with my
kids and i'm just like
and i'm thinking [ __ ] you you've had
that it was clear from the post that
they've had the luxury
of working from home yeah and not losing
their job
and they could teach their kids and it's
this idea of not opening the public
schools
these kids out here who don't have wi-fi
who don't have laptops
who have a one-parent home who has to
work
all those that can't afford a tutor
can't make a little pod to teach their
kids
you know those people aren't doing well
right and those kids are suffering
and then you get like the people who can
afford to
set up a private pod for their kids and
bring a tutor in
and have strong wi-fi and can do all
those things have english as a first
language
and they're doing just fine and they're
like well we should not go back to
school
[ __ ] you kids have disappeared off the
radar during this past year
and the schools don't even know where
they are in places like new york and
chicago and other places so
it's it's [ __ ] up yeah you know it's
there's narratives out there and the
problem with these narratives are it's
not that they're all
completely inaccurate the problem is
when you say when you
when you espouse these narratives in a
very condensed
processed way like social media you get
a bunch of people that support it a
bunch of people that argue against it
but if it's a narrative like we should
stay home we should all wear masks
pretty hard for people to fight against
that right so people
they they pile on and then and then
people get addicted to like the
reactions and the interactions on
twitter and it's like
it becomes this weird [ __ ] method of
communication the
method of discussing ideas and they get
people get
really attached to whatever whatever
they believe in whether they believe the
kids should be in school to the end of
time and
all all [ __ ] interactions should be
done through zoom
or that we should all throw away our
masks and achieve herd immunity and you
should take vitamin d
and go out in the sun and [ __ ]
exercise and be healthier and
you can do you can do all of it right
you can wear a mask because you know
okay fine
who care my freedoms aren't infringed by
wearing a mask i don't give a [ __ ] it's
not that big a deal
yeah but at the same time do i want my
kids back in school
do i think it's healthy for my oldest
boy sluggo to you know
be wearing his you know pajamas or his
sweatpants all day long and learning
from distance no
and i think that it's just so there are
i
you know i do agree with the idea that
there there are people that that suffer
well
they're kind of wielding this whole
thing as long as it's a sword of justice
yeah
so well you know a good exam the comedy
community is an interesting example
because
one of the things that uh a lot of my
professional comedian friends have found
is that there's a lot of people that
never worked
and when i say never i'm exaggerating
but they weren't they weren't successful
they didn't they weren't selling out
clubs and theaters they weren't doing
well
and they're so angry that some comics
have decided to go on the road again
because a lot of places have opened up
texas has opened up florida's opened up
you can go and do shows but that's a
chance to do work right i mean so
it is but they're angry and they they
want the
the narrative is that you're doing these
super spreader events people even got
mad at me and dave chappelle
because dave and i were doing these
shows at stubs amphitheater in austin
outside
there's no evidence whatsoever that the
the the virus spreads outside
and i mean literally none there's no
evidence and then on top of that we test
everyone in the crowd it's expensive it
takes a long time the people get there
early
we test the entire group are you doing
temperature checks no we're doing we're
doing uh
antigen tests for the entire crowd
that's crazy yeah i mean that's great
but it's crazy it's expensive but it's
the way to do it and we had a great
[ __ ] time and we're doing it again
and but some comics have been mad at
that but if you go and look at the
comics that are mad they're all
unsuccessful yeah or super liberal
and they're virtue signaling they're
looking to to like
tag on to this idea that what you're
doing is bad and then what we should do
is all stay home and
lock down like you can go outside and by
the way
most people like 99.9
whatever percent survive there was a
recent study that showed that
78 of all the people that are
hospitalized from covid are overweight
have you seen that yeah i've seen that
yeah where is the shame
all these people are talking about fat
shaming you want to talk about the super
spreaders
it's people that have ignored their
health and those people need help and
they need support and they need love
but there's a reality to the people that
are getting sick from this
if everyone was healthy this would
almost be a non-issue
now that's not a health-shaming thing
like we should be shaming people that
are in poor health or people that are
born with
you know um comorbidity factors like
diabetes or whatever of course of course
yeah yeah
but the re we're not looking at this
thing 100
objective if we were we would have a
completely different take on it
well look there's no science this is
that's an example guy i'm focused
because i got
these i got these three knuckleheads at
home right so i'm focused on like the
the education side of things as well and
so
as as are you but it's there's no
science people believe science of course
believe science that that's one of the
funniest narratives believe science well
who the [ __ ] doesn't believe i mean if
that's fine but it's a political issue
right so
but i think that uh there's no science
that shows that that
you know a six foot distance in public
schools for kids
right is is is uh is
essential to their health so in fact the
science shows three foot that's fine
and what that does though the importance
of that is logistics right because it
allows for you to get the schools open
again
people will talk about this six foot
distance we can't get these kids back
into their classrooms with six foot
distances we can't get enough of them in
there
it's the little things it's the
logistics of it saying well get it down
to three foot which is what the science
supports and then you can get these
schools you can start opening these
places back up in a responsible manner
honestly god we're going to look at this
thing in a year or two maybe we won't
because we're not going to be honest
with ourselves
but if we actually did an honest hot
wash of this reaction to the pandemic
our reaction has been pathetic right
over over this past
year i this has not been a shining
moment for us don't you think part of
the problem is we started out
with a different idea what the virus is
we started out thinking that it was
going to be like the next spanish flu
and it was going to kill i mean everyone
was terrified me included i was scared
of it
in the beginning i thought that it was
going to be something that kills 10
of the population you know and it didn't
turn out to be that way but we never
made an adjustment
yeah no i yes i think that's true and i
think also
part of it is is you can't negate the uh
or minimize the political reaction right
if if if joe biden had been president
when this thing broke i guarantee you
their action would have been somewhat
different
the fact that trump was in there and
created so much emotion
um and there was such animosity uh
thank god trump wasn't pro-vaccine we
would be [ __ ]
because you know he was pro so many
other therapeutics and they're like
hydroxychloroquine is racist
you know like yeah thank god he didn't
say anything about ivermectin
or vitamin d or quercetin or any of the
other things that we've been or zinc
yeah but i do think that you know that
was a big issue was was like
see he's so polarizing and we can't and
we can't trust the the vaccines because
you know they were developed under trump
right [ __ ] it believe the science they
were developed by
companies that have nothing but
scientists and doctors and engineers
working inside them yeah and so if you
believe the science and you better
believe that they were developing
vaccines
that you should have been happy about so
you know like
everything you know i don't know it's
it's the political nature of this
country
and and again going back to what we were
talking about earlier with the russians
and the chinese they see that and they
just keep they keep
sticking right yeah and and the more
they do the more they tear the threads
of our belief from the system
and the more polarized we get the more
yelling that goes on and
the more [ __ ] people believe when
they read social media and they don't
bother to say well who wrote this right
is this actually a scientific piece of
work or is this just
and what's the origin of it what's the
outlet right and half the time the
outlet is overseas someplace and then
you got to dig into it
it's like an asset tracing exercise who
owns that company right then you find
out it's owned by some
you know russian entity that's got an
operation out of cyprus or whatever
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience